come to the new hampshire house of
representatives
i'd like to remind myself every time i'm
in this hall that the five gentlemen on
the wall behind me knew nothing about my
existence when the things they did were
so important nor did anybody else in
this hall
and that they will be here long after i
am here debating the the issues of the
day but what they are here for is for
um the principles and the things that
drive us and get us here together to
have the discussion we're going to have
here this morning so i always like to
sort of pay a little special attention
to them because what they did help us do
was sort of chart the way as to how we
would proceed and this is state business
um and in that regards i would like to
start the meeting this morning with the
pledge of allegiance
of the united states
thank you very much everyone
i'm going to have a seat we are live
streaming this um i want to make sure
that people who are watching and there
were like two people logged in an hour
before we even began
so i want to make sure that everyone can
hear what is going on so this mic is on
to my right and left are members of
the house
redistricting committee they are here
with me today for this public input
session on maps
as you all know we are here for
redistricting this is a event that
occurs throughout the country in every
state after the census is completed we
have been to each county throughout the
state for a public information
session so that we can get input as to
what the various communities in our
counties
might have for thoughts as to how we
should proceed with maps
since those information sensors sessions
we have drafted maps as a committee
those were posted online last week and
if you came in today and had an
opportunity to see the table we have
copies for you
so you have something in front of you
today to look at so we are here today
and tomorrow at five o'clock
to hear your input on
the maps that are proposed there are two
maps proposed for every district
the things that we are focused on on our
committee are commissioners which are
elected by county
house representatives again elected by
county
and the congressional districts
which are elected by two counties
through two divisions one division two
districts throughout the state
i have a blue sheet out front for people
to sign up if they'd like to speak this
is how we handled it in the public
information session sessions and it
seemed to work all right my purpose i'm
simply going to go through
the list here and ask people to come to
one of the microphones it is my
understanding that each of these
microphones are on
so you will be able to be heard not only
by people here in the chamber with you
but also by people who are looking
online
so
with that i would like to get started
i will note that there we have
designated sections four and five for
face covering so if you would be more
comfortable sitting in an area where
everyone around you will have a face
covering on i invite you to move to
section four or five of the hall
i've sat in a number of seats you get a
good view everywhere so
feel free to move
and with that
i would like to start out we have a
number of people here it is not my
intent to limit the time for testimony
sometimes when we do testimony we limit
it to three minutes
uh as representatives when we go to
what's referred to as the well behind me
to my right and my left
what we are told is after three minutes
uh you need to get your point across or
or people are not following it
members of the committee will certainly
be following you but i'm not going to be
cutting people off unless i think it's
getting really repetitive or we get a
significantly more amount of people in
here and i'm worried about people being
able to speak if people come and they
want to speak i want to make sure we can
hear them
so with that i'm going to start and the
first person who signed up
is janet ward janet ms ward where are
you welcome ms word miss ward i and i
won't do this for everybody but i will
give her honorable mention she came to a
community input session she has written
the committee and i think we just got an
email yesterday from this ward yes
indeed you did
welcome
thank you
um so the united states supreme court
can you get a little closer certainly
how's this much better okay
the united states supreme court observed
that the process of redistricting which
often involves gerrymandering
is a political process
and that it would not become involved in
that process
this was a bad decision on the part of
the supreme court why
because the purely political
act of gerrymandering
effectively silences the voices
of legitimate voters
and makes it impossible for voters to
have their votes truly count
the fact is
that gerrymandering
turns democracy on its head
it enables candidates to choose their
voters
and denies voters the right to choose
their candidates
everyone on this committee understands
that
any reasonable person who has looked at
the republican map
of u.s congressional district 1 and
congressional district 2
can see that its convoluted borders
serve one purpose and one purpose only
as drawn
this map lets republican candidates
running in district 1
select their voters
while district 2
lets democratic candidates choose theirs
yes
voters will cast their votes in these
districts but the outcome is
predetermined
in these packed
cracked
purposely and artfully drawn
gerrymandered districts
what the republican members of the
special committee on redistricting have
done
is to silence the voices of voters
democrats republicans and independents
alike
this is a display of raw political power
and it is wrong
what good is an election if
gerrymandering makes it essentially
meaningless
thank you
thank you miss ward next signed up is
maureen quinn
from deerfield
deerfield
i would like to thank the committee for
this opportunity to speak before you
this morning
and to convey my concerns with the
proposed map for the redistricting of
state legislative representatives in new
hampshire
i'm from the town of deerfield where
this past spring by a margin of more
than two to one
voters vote
more than two to one voters voted their
desire for this committee to minimize
multi-seat districts
i'm not originally from new hampshire
but i did spend all my childhood summers
and went to college here
i love new hampshire as my second home
and i chose to come back here to new
hampshire after working for several
years in other states
i wanted to raise my children here
in part because of the quality of life
that i believe existed for myself and my
family in new hampshire
coming back here as an adult i knew that
there were two very particular things
that defined new hampshire and its
approach to policy and politics
and those two things were the state
motto
live free or die
and the governing concept of local
control
these are more than slogans they were
part of what makes new hampshire unique
live for your dive to me meant
maintaining a limited role for
government
to not have unnecessary governmental
influence in people's lives as they make
a life for themselves and their families
but it also communicates how vitally
important this state considers freedom
and a democratic system of government to
be
included in that value of freedom is the
right to have one's voice heard
local control meant that the citizens of
new hampshire have a close relationship
too and could have a direct impact on
how their communities are run
they would know who was making the
decisions on their behalf and could
communicate easily with policy makers
because they were members of the same
community
and in the last 26 years of living here
i have heard these principles cited over
and over again by policy makers as the
rationale for many a piece of
legislation or other
policy
in looking at the proposed maps for
state legislative districts i scratch my
head and wonder where these two vitally
new hampshire concepts have gone
i attended more than one of the public
hearings held by this committee in the
counties across the state
and what i heard from many people across
many many towns
was the desire to have their communities
be represented by a single state
representative
again and again
it was said that the ability for a town
to choose who represents them in the
legislature
without their vote being diluted or
skewed by voters in an adjoining town or
towns was a priority
having someone who truly knows your
community and its unique needs and
concerns as laws and policies are
crafted here in this building is
invaluable
and allows for the local voice to be
part of the process
it is consistent with the concept and
the values of local control
the continued use of multi-town
districts when towns clearly desire and
the state constitution supports the
critical value that town-specific
representation provides is disheartening
particularly when these proposed
districts have the same number of
representatives as the number of towns
so there's no rationale the rationale
cannot be
re restrictions needed in the number of
representatives
multi-town districts reduce the voices
of voters and because that because of
that they weaken the democratic
underpinnings of our government
they should not be used in or they
should be used only in situations where
the numbers make them unavoidable
the maps is currently proposed feel very
much like unnecessary governmental
influence
if the voices of the people are not
heard then we are not truly free and our
state motto live free or die has been
gutted what we have lost was what makes
new hampshire new hampshire
thank you
thank you ms quinn
ellen farnham
i attended the special committee work
sessions on number on november 3rd
let me make sure i'm on the beginning
yes on november 3rd and 4th when these
maps were first presented
i want to begin by saying that i
appreciate the time and effort the
committee has spent to make sure that
the maps could meet the constitutional
and state requirements and i especially
want to thank the committee for this
opportunity to now speak about the
proposals
i sincerely hope that you will take my
comments and the comments of other
granite staters into consideration
before you finalize your decisions
first
could you just state what uh town you're
from it makes it easier for us thank you
i'm ellen farnham from tamworth
first i want to raise my heart the
congressional map drawn by the majority
this republican plan would destroy the
competitive congressional districts in
our state
i went back and reviewed the voting
records for both districts for the past
140 years
both district 1 and district 2 have
historically swung between republican
representation and democratic
representation
this has been a good thing
we want our districts to be competitive
competitive districts help unify our
state as candidates must appeal to
voters with diverse ideas
competitive districts also bring about
the very best candidates
the map the
map created by republicans would not
only transfer 75 towns in the state to a
new district but would create two highly
partisan
clearly gerrymandered districts
the majorities map transfers the key
republican leaning districts of hudson
salem and windham to district one while
at the same time shifting democratic
leaning dover in durham from
congressional district one to district
2.
i believe that the members of this
committee will lose credibility if they
do not modify the majority congressional
plan
fair non-partisan redistricting is
popular with voter voters and these
hearings are being watched closely
i recommend using the nonpartisan map
drawn by the citizen mapping project
mapathon
this map maintains integrity competitive
districts and keeps communities of
interest together
i also support the minority map
democratic members of the committee
succeeded in maintaining competitive
districts and did not need to move huge
numbers of voters into new districts to
comply with the constitutional and state
rules
as a carroll county resident i would
also like to comment on the proposed
house plans
i acknowledge how complex this process
is for creating these districts
both the democratic and republican plans
have advantages and are similar in every
in many ways
however i prefer the democratic plan
which creates smaller districts i
believe that the smaller districts make
it easier for our representatives to
know their communities and i also think
more candidates would run for house if
the districts were smaller as the
campaigns would not be so expensive
my first choice for a carroll county map
is reserved for mapathon a map that
places tamworth madison freedom
effingham and eaton together
even though the
the the deviations are lower under this
plan and the map maintains smaller
districts
groups communities of interest together
and helps more qualifying towns have
their own representative
thank you very much
um chair i was given a very short
statement from someone um
from wolfeboro may i read that sure go
ahead is that all right it's very short
okay this is from ruth
sexton wolf bro new hampshire
and it's to the new hampshire house
redistricting committee members
she writes i am outraged after reviewing
material on the proposed republican
redistricting changes for new hampshire
new hampshire is the cradle of american
democracy let us not defile this
deep-rooted tradition through partisan
rancor
thank you would you like me to leave a
copy of these statements with you chair
actually you can give it to uh the woman
sitting at the table in the auntie room
thank you i'll do that later that's
we're going to collate
they will collate and they will be
scanned and emailed to the com
because obviously we don't expect you
all to bring multiple copies so we thank
the people that did
the next person signed up to speak is
maureen mann from deerfield
hi uh first thank you
for
the time you have put in i can't imagine
how hard it was to do the state rep
districts
however what i'm here to talk about is
northeast rockingham county okay
so
basically what i'm going to even though
i know how difficult it is and i do
understand some of the issues
i'd like the committee members to
reconsider
the
towns of deerfield northwood nottingham
candia and auburn
each has the population for its own rep
i have to speak through the mask
oh i'm sorry
okay uh the five towns of deerfield
northwood nottingham candia and auburn
each has the population for its own rep
but instead they are combined in either
one of the plans here in two towns and
three towns the other swaps deerfield
back and forth between the two districts
so i'd like you to reconsider but i
understand
that
you've worked on this forever so instead
i'd like to speak specifically to the
way the plans were made
right now the majority plan says
deerfield auburn
and candia
the minority plan says deerfield
northwood in nottingham
if the towns have to be combined
i would appreciate you really looking at
what the towns have in common
for instance
deerfield northwood and nottingham have
the same state rep excuse me state
senate district
candy and auburn are in a different
district
candy and auburn send their kids to
pinkerton
deerfield northwood and nottingham all
send some kids to co brown
candy and auburn are suburbs of
manchester
deerfield northwood in nottingham
either aimed toward the seacoast or
toward concord
uh
candia and auburn are slower growing
than the other three communities by a
large margin which probably explains why
candia
hasn't had
elected a person from candia
since in almost 10 years because it's
the smallest town in both plans
and it really is overwhelmed by the
larger communities
none of our towns other than northwood
co-ground have their own high schools so
middle school sports are really
important and keep our communities
together
northwood nottingham and deerfield are
all part of the southeast league
parents are involved with the southeast
league schools are involved with the
southeast league and there are big deals
in our small town
auburn and candia belong to a different
league
deerfield shares a state park
pawtuckaway state park with nottingham
it shares northwood meadows state park
with northwood
and deerfield shares
a lake
two different lakes with northwood
northwood lake even though it's
northwood lake is half in deerfield
pleasant lake which people think it's in
deerfield is half in northwood
so if these towns cannot be given their
own representatives
i would really appreciate your
consideration
looking at
what the towns have in common
communities of interest make a
difference deerfield and nottingham at
one point were the same community so
they have a lot of historic and cultural
things that happen together
i appreciate your time i have a handout
and
part of the handout which i will give to
looks at the data
and if you look at the standard
deviations for both the majority and the
minority plan
are
basically much narrower
than the standard deviation for
rockingham county which is plus and
minus five
if deerfield can now have its own rep
i would much prefer
and the people of deerfield and as
maureen quinn said
overwhelmingly have asked for their own
rep if deerfield cannot have its own rep
then please consider putting deerfield
with northwood in nottingham which
culturally historically educationally
has much more in common
than deerfield with either
candia or auburn thank you
thank you
representative peter petrogno
thank you very much madam chair members
of the committee i'm peter petrino and i
represent hillsboro 23 the town of
milford
and i'm here to speak in support of the
minority plan
that puts milford and amherst in the
same floateria district
it makes perfect sense from a historical
geographic cultural
and social perspective
milford and amherst are like two peas in
the pod
they're twin sisters with a very long
shared
history
milford was once part of amherst before
becoming its own town
in more recent times amherst students
attended high school at the milford area
senior high school before souhegan high
school was built
my children played and now my
granddaughter plays with kids from
amherst on various youth sports programs
kids from amherst participate in the
boys and girls club
in milford
residents of amherst are parishioners at
st patrick's church
in milford
the minority plan
would put milford
in with brookline
greenville
wine borough
mason mount vernon new ipswich temple
and wilton
it just doesn't make any sense
it's a 20-minute walk
a three-minute car ride from the milford
oval
to the amherst border
it is a 20-minute car ride
a four-hour walk from the milford oval
to greenville
conversely the majority plan puts
amherst with hollis
but the minority plan
has hollis with brookline
now that makes sense
because hollis brookline
share the same school district
hollis brookline high school
so from my perspective this really is a
matter of
representatives coming from the
community that they know
it's very likely that the representative
could live in amherst and attend church
in milford
or that the representative could come
from milford
and their children play on the soccer
team
in amherst
so
i just asked for your consideration with
that full turial to combine the combined
milford with amherst thank you very much
for your attention and for all your hard
work thank you
thank you
representative lee oxenham
there you are
are you able to hear me with the mask on
if if you pull the mic down and are
closer to it i think we'll be fine thank
you very much yeah we're fine
chatham chair colleagues members of the
public
i'm representative lee oxenoum and i
represent sullivan county district one
with representative brian sullivan
we share
representing plainfield cornish grantham
and springfield and we also share in the
plateau district represented by
representative linda tanner
first i want to register my constituents
overwhelming opposition to the flagrant
gerrymandering of our congressional
districts
but i want to focus my remarks here
today
on my own district
i strongly urge the redistricting
committee to reject the majority map
with its proposed severing of the
current district one into several
fragmented units
cornish and plainfield in particular are
integrally interwoven and must not be
separated
the two share commercial establishments
electronic and print media
they have interwoven neighborhoods and
innumerable roads and bridges in common
they provide each other with police and
fire backup
we shared the cornish rescue ambulance
service our churches share congregants
our elementary schools share their
superintendent
we share each other's libraries we
combine our town energy committees we
have an aging in place group which
provides resources and services across
town boundaries and shares medical
equipment to seniors at no cost
we are both connecticut river
communities and share many issues from
bank erosion and flooding to public
access for recreation that none of the
other towns have any interest or concern
in
when severe bank erosion threatened the
integrity of route 12a and the viability
of commercial establishments in both
communities
district one's shared representatives
were able to effectively advocate for
alterations in the department of
transportation's plans
when speeding issues threatened lives
and safety on route 120 again we were
able to bring twice the influence
more than just one rep's voice to bear
in search of solutions for our
constituents
please contrast this with the majorities
map
which takes plainfield and puts it in
one district takes cornish and puts it
in another district and then links the
two towns with two towns with which they
have nothing in common
according to the majorities map there is
a contiguous area between plainfield and
croydon
in fact this doesn't exist there's a
private game reserve on that mountain
and it has cut off any communication you
cannot hike to croydon you certainly
cannot drive a car to croydon without
going out of the town and around on the
interstate
the majority map gives a false
impression that this is a fairly large
area it's about four or five hundred
feet
a similar thing happens to cornish with
their link to newport it's a theoretical
point but there's no road there there's
no contiguity to go from cornish to
newport you have to go down to claremont
drive east and then go north again
to reach that area there are no
administrative social historic
geographic
church rescue police ties between these
communities they do not share a
commonality of interest
so i please ask you to reconsider this
glaring
injustice
your gis maps may show a croydon
mountain road that goes over the
mountain but it's long since
not been able to be used
um
okay and i would just leave you with
this thought
please leave district 1 in its current
configuration it works well and i've
heard no complaints from any
of my constituents on of either partisan
configuration
uh the
so
my the first the first ask is leave it
alone
and my second ask is please adopt the
minority map which would keep playing
field and cornish together
thank you very much
thank you
liz tentarelli
thank you for this opportunity to
present testimony my name is liz
tentarelli i live in newberry
the westernmost town in merrimack county
among new hampshire's 239
populated cities and towns fewer than
half
are large enough to qualify for their
own state representatives
so today i want to address the situation
of the 135
small towns with populations under that
target number
and many of them including my town of
newbury are never going to reach that
target number
of having our own rep
one of the joys of living in a small
town is knowing your elected officials
personally
seeing them at town events at the
transfer station a kind of neighbor to
neighbor relationship
and i won't try to speak for anyone else
but many of us consider our
representatives political party
affiliation
less important than what they are doing
in the town
now in our huge house of representatives
called a citizen legislature for good
reason
most of uh most of the representatives
are coming from larger towns and cities
of course
you know mathematically that happens
but even our large cities have tried to
maintain a feeling of localized
representation
by dividing themselves into wards
so that with a small number of
representatives from each ward
the interests of the neighborhoods in
each ward will be considered at the
state level
the problem for small towns is that when
they are grouped into large multi-seat
districts with a number of other towns
we lose our connection to localized
representation
now none of us expect that we're going
to have a rep from our own town each
time
but we do want and hope that this
committee will facilitate a plan
that groups just a few contiguous towns
into a district
whose representatives will know the
concerns
and interests of the issues in all of
those towns
what we do not want to see is four or
five or more towns grouped with a much
larger town
where the candidates from that much
larger town can easily dominate an
election just by having an address in
that large town
this happened with the 2001
redistricting
and it was so bad that that had to be
redone before the next election
it also led to the constitutional
amendment of 2006
that made floaterials official
but also called for those towns that
meet the threshold of for representation
to be allotted their own maps
and of course we know that's not always
possible i applaud your efforts to do
that as much as you can
with both the minority and the majority
maps
but let's get back to the small towns
like mine that don't qualify
we too were considered in that
2006 amendment
even though it's rarely mentioned now
so attached to my written testimony is a
page from the house election law
committee
dated february 22nd 2006.
it is the statement of intent
of
cacr4 and that's the proposal
that was recommended unanimously by the
committee passed in the house and senate
and then passed by the voters
in november of 2006
with more than a 70
support
so i'm going to read that statement of
intent because i think it is very
important
the long-standing tradition in new
hampshire is to have
as many small representative districts
as possible
so as to best represent all the people
of new hampshire
this cacr as amended will allow the
legislature to use floateral districts
as used in the past without question or
challenges in the courts
this will make sure that our state will
have
as many small house districts as
possible
now of course the amendment the
the actual amendment has passed deals
with those towns that reach the
threshold for their own representative
but that statement of intent applies to
the smaller than currently 139 smaller
towns as well
so i'm asking the committee to look at
each of the proposed house maps
find and recommend those that have as
many small representative districts as
possible
so that the new maps will best represent
all the people of new hampshire
i personally could tolerate a larger
deviation
in order to get that kind of localized
representation
i got specific about four counties my
own county of merrimack of course
carroll county cheshire county and
sullivan county with some specific
comments that deal with the small towns
those not eligible for their own rep and
that is in my written testimony and i
hope you will look at that when you get
to your deliberations next week thank
you for this opportunity
thank you
james fresher from dover is signed up to
speak
i'm going to take off the mask because i
sound muffled i'm also very good at
stepping on my on my wife's toes when we
dance i just miss this gentleman over
here
i'm james fisher from dover new
hampshire retired physician
and i'm
speaking against the current proposed
maps
um
i was also speaking in
stratham
stafford i'm sorry
in a stafford county
courthouse when this committee met
and i asked
at that time that
we not use
politics as a consideration for map
drawing and in fact
i
stayed throughout that whole meeting and
and
that
opinion was unanimous i i have no idea
what happened at any of the other
sessions that
that you attended
but i know in stratfor county that was
that was the unanimous consent
with the recent
redistricting committee's proposed map
it's clear that
i guess at least the majority decided to
ignore those requests
and base their decision at least part if
not wholly on
political considerations giving
advantage to the republicans
and not only is the action of redrawing
voting districts in favor of one party
over the other the very definition of
gerrymandering
but that action also reflects the
purpose of gerrymandering and that is to
either ignore or bypass
the voice and opinion of voters
this proposal not only reduces the
number of spring swing districts
but increasingly divides municipalities
and school districts into different
voting districts making it more
difficult to pass local legislation
aimed at fixing local educational and
municipal problems
if the current redistricting proposal
passes granite staters in the next
decade will look upon the past decade as
the golden years of government function
swing districts
are essential to any democracy
it forces candidates to develop ideas
and strategies that benefit
most of the voters in that district
not just the voters within their own
party
by using political party as a criteria
for forming voting districts
everyone gets hurt
republicans democrats
and independents
republicans and democratic districts
will have little or no say in the local
issues just as democrats in republican
districts will have little or no say but
even worse
the more vocal extremes of each party
will have a bigger say in party politics
leaving moderates and independents with
no voice
and no recourse in either party
with gerrymandering elected officials
only need to concern themselves with the
interests of the larger and more often
radical subdivisions with their within
their own political parties that makes
elections general elections less
valuable
and primary elections more valuable
which hurts independence
gerrymandering has radicalized democracy
it's empowered some groups of people
while disenfranchising
disenfranchising others
we have moved from a government
belonging to the voters to a government
where the voters belong to politicians
we've moved away from a system of checks
and balances
to
a government where political leaders are
free
from responsibility and accountability
from either
party the
redistricting plan is little more than a
power grab at this point and will hurt
all granite staters regardless of their
party of
affiliation
it divides the municipalities and school
districts and will further divide
neighbor against neighbor
in a polarizing effect
the short-term gain
that
this
map
proposes for republicans
and whatever you may
feel you may achieve from that will be
more than offset
by further frustration
and loss of confidence in our state and
municipal governments
i pray that's not your
your goal
we live in a in a world now where
information is siloed
we have uh social media using
algorithms to divide people and to
emphasize the more radical aspects of
either party
we have
specific cable news channels
catering to liberals and
and conservatives
and gerrymandering only adds to that
it discourages
residents from talking to each other
and it hurts our ability to talk to our
own neighbors to resolve these issues
where all of the issues that plague us
now whether it's marijuana whether it's
abortions you name it
this has to be done at a local level not
at the national level
and maybe not even at the state level
so i urge you to reconsider your map
drawing
and i thank you not only for your
citizenship
for your time and effort on this
committee but also for the time of
allowing me to speak thank you very much
also signed up to speak from the aclu
henry
i'm i i'm out of practice henry i
apologize i have butchered enough names
this year no problem thank you my name
is henry clemento i would have gotten it
right yes absolutely
i'm a staff attorney at the aclu of new
hampshire we are a non-partisan
nonprofit organization in the new
hampshire affiliate of the american
civil liberties union which is a 2
million member strong nationally civil
rights group so i've submitted written
testimony and i'm not going to repeat it
all but i just have three quick points
that i'd like to make about the state
house maps and then one about the
congressional map
uh the first point i'd like to make
about the state house map is that it
over over-represents the city of
claremont and under-represents the city
of manchester
as you know part two article nine of the
new hampshire constitution requires
state house districts shall be as equal
as circumstances we'll admit and both
the new hampshire and and u.s
constitution
have a system in which
where the ideal where the maximum
deviation and the minimum deviation add
up to less than 10 percent it's
considered
presumptively in compliance with that
mandate but uh according to vinovich
versus quilter which is at 507 u.s 146
any plan with larger disparities in
population creates a prima facie case of
discrimination and therefore must be
justified by the state
so the the deviation in the three wards
in claremont right now is negative six
percent and in manchester it's positive
uh four point nine four percent which is
almost 11 and therefore outside the
threshold uh and so a court reviewing
this plan would not give the state the
benefit of the doubt that it wasn't
discriminating against people and not
complying with a one person one vote
threshold
moreover baked into the calculation is
the assumption that both cities are
going to perfectly redistrict their
wards into equal population when that's
probably not the case so in manchester
the deviation is 4.94
but my rough calculation suggests that
if
two or three more people are in one ward
of manchester then another that's going
to take us above the five percent
threshold and the same thing is going to
happen in claremont so what looks on
paper like an 11 deviation may end up
being more like 12 or 13 once the cities
uh
redraw the wards and that's going to
raise constitutional concerns and i
imagine would invite litigation down the
line
the second point i'd like to make is
that the current plan
at least opens the door for a racial
gerrymander in nashua
according to the most recent census
figures uh 13.7 percent of people in
nashua identify as
as hispanic or latinx and the city has
been apportioned 27 state
representatives and so you would figure
with 13.7 percent of the population
uh identifying as hispanic or latinx you
might have three or four districts that
are majority minority
what this committee has done under both
the majority and the minority plans
is
uh just award three districts three
representatives to each ward and leave
left it to the city to draw the ward
lines and so you could end up in a
situation where you have zero minority
majority districts
and under thornburg versus jingles which
is at 478 u.s 30 1986 the supreme court
considered the implications of a
multi-member district under section two
of the voting rights act which
prohibits
voting practices or procedures that
discriminate on the basis of race color
or membership in a designated language
minority group
i think that it's the responsibility of
this committee to examine whether single
member districts in nashua could be
drawn in a way that would comply with
the voting rights act and i understand
that this the state constitution
requires that wards be kept together and
not divided up into single member
districts but the new hampshire
constitution can't override the federal
voting rights act which under uh
uh the us constitution article six
paragraph two provides that the
the federal law is the supreme law of
the land and so
in in thornburg versus jingles the
supreme court struck down multi-member
districts in the north carolina general
assembly because they found that they
had the effect
of unfairly disadvantaged disadvantaging
uh black voters and the same could be
true in nashua and i think that this
committee should investigate
whether the maps that it's drawing
comply with the voting rights act
the third point i want to make about the
state house plan is to inform the
committee of the results of our analysis
we hired a company called flow analytics
which is a data
analysis firm to calculate the mean
median partisan lien
under the current plans and the proposed
majority plans and so the mean median
partisan lien is the difference in
partisan lien between the state as a
whole and the medium district which is
to say the district
that's 200 or 201st out of the 400 um
on the left right divide
so under the current plan the mean
median seat lien currently tilts towards
republicans by 0.08 percent and under
the proposed plan it tilt towards
republicans by 1.3
so that's a significant increase in the
difference between
the partisan of the state as a whole and
the median district and is one of the
commonly used statistics
to evaluate whether a plan constitutes a
partisan gerrymander and under our
analysis
this plan does
finally i just want to make a point that
i'm sure others will make two and i've
heard made before about house bill 52
which is the reapportionment of the
congressional districts
this plan
has the effect of shifting over a
quarter of new hampshire's population
into a different congressional district
and severing the relationship between
the voter and their current
representative
and has the effect of shifting the
partisan lien of each district by six
points
and so what it does according to 538
which is a political science and
statistics website is it would turn new
hampshire's two competitive
congressional districts into one
guaranteed democratic district in one
guaranteed republican district
noted unh political science professor
dante scala has explained that he and
his research assistant tried to draw a
map that would have greater partisan
advantage for the republicans and were
unable to do so
so i'll just leave that with you all and
i'm happy to take any questions now or
by email later thank you
thank
you signed up is ruth larson
from
alton
because i'm not that tall
is that okay yes
good morning my name is ruth larson i
live in alton new hampshire in belknap
county i'm a liberal democrat in a very
red town in a very red county so i'm
used to being in the minority
i have been a supervisor of the
checklist in alton spending as i joke my
free time registering one republican
voter after another including at
elections when we have same-day
registration when sometimes i am there
for 12 hours and do not register a
single person in my own town count in my
own party excuse me
um but i do it because i believe in the
power of the vote the power of the vote
for all not just people with whom i
share political views
when i testified at the belknap county
listening session in laconia i expressed
my confidence
that this committee
would do the right thing
at this point my confidence has seemed
to be a little bit misplaced
based on the evidence provided so far
but i am not giving up
with regard to the new hampshire house
seats
i am concerned that the committee
majority maps seem to have almost
totally abandoned the goal of localized
representation even in situations where
the obvious result would be to have
separate districts with towns having
their own representatives your maps
combined towns multi-town districts
become the norm
there are other maps available and one
of them is being provided
to you later in testimony by don house
of belmont and i would support that map
with regard to belknap county as
being much better
matched to the goal of localized
representation
i would also remind the committee that
the one-person one-vote
rule is flexible the u.s constitution
allows for variation
especially with regard to the deviation
we keep hearing about
but if you're going to do away with
localized representation
then let's do away with the
new hampshire house of representatives
having 400 members
there is only one reason why we have
such a ridiculously
large legislature and that is to provide
localized representation
if you hired somebody to go out and
survey people
in towns where they
are represented by
legislators from other towns
it would be very interesting to see how
many of them
have ever met their representative
how many of them
can name their representative how many
of them even recognize the name of their
representative when you provide it
we had a concrete example of that in
laconia in testimony where a
representative stood up and said he
liked representing two towns
and then we heard right after him
a citizen from the town he did not live
in stand up and said i rode in the
elevator with this man i've never seen
him before i don't even know who he is
as for the congressional districts
the majority map is nothing short of a
disgrace and it is a huge disappointment
there hasn't even been an attempt to
disguise this blatant grab for political
power it violates every standard of
decency
and
most importantly it is a slap in the
face to all of the new hampshire voters
who supported the fair redistricting
in their town votes
and i remind you all that that was a
non-partisan effort that united people
from all sides of the political spectrum
my very conservative town of alton
joined other red towns and purple towns
and blue towns to vote yes to fair
districting
if we ask you why you chose to provide a
gerrymandered map for the congressional
to be your answer
i sincerely hope that it is not because
we can
that's not the legacy that you should
want
you want to be able to tell your
children and grandchildren that you
stood up for fairness for all
not that you acted out of part as part
partisan politicians or party
opportunists
with your congressional map you have
packed one party into a district making
it a very safe seat and the other party
in the other district
so safe is a democratic district
that
outcomes of elections will be decided
totally at the nomination level
stage of the process voters in the other
party will have a meaningless vote they
will essentially be disenfranchised
as you probably know gerrymandering
contributes to polarization
favoring nomination of candidates on the
edges or the fringes of each party
the end result
cynicism on both sides of the aisle
something we already have more of than
most of us
want
although i no longer feel as optimistic
as i did when i spoke in laconia it is
nevertheless my hope that you will think
about the voters of new hampshire all
the voters and listen to their voice and
do what you know is right as i said in
laconia we can't make you do the right
thing
only you can do that
thank you
i also have a letter to submit from
diana lacy of belmont
who
is a
i'll bring that down it's directed to
representative o'hara her representative
and all committee members thank you very
thank you very much
thank you miss larson and thank you for
working the polls it's important for all
of our districts also signed up to speak
is
megan murray
that would be rep i thought that would
be representative megan
thank you for having me uh thank you
colleagues for the record my name is
megan murray i represent the town of
amherst district 22.
um i submitted to the folks in the back
table again the letter from the town
board of selectmen for the mic yeah
thank you i submitted again for the
record the letter from the amherst board
of selectmen requesting
um by a vote of
1613 to 543
that um by petition
that
pursuant to new hampshire state
constitution part 2 article 11 that
allows town's sufficient population to
have their own state representatives not
shared with other towns for the town of
amherst to partition the new hampshire
general court and it for its own
exclusive seat or seats in the new
hampshire house of representatives
ensuring that the state representatives
properly represent the town's interests
that said given the maps that we have
before us to consider
i would like to say that
i echo the sentiments of the
representative from milford in stating
the preference for pragmatic reasons
of
shared interest in community
services and resources throughout the
town of milford and amherst and i think
that that is a natural pairing between
the two but that given um i did want to
make sure that you again had the letter
from the amherst board of selectmen so
thank you for your time
thank you
deborah nelson is signed up to speak
she's from hanover
thank you very much i assumed you would
be limiting the length of my
we can do that if you want
i mean so i pre-limited them
but i want first of all to thank you all
very much for the work that you are
doing
i commend you for having figured out how
to use those
flash drives that you were given
and i would
highly recommend
that you seek out and study the maps
presented by the mapathon and the fair
maps group
to
[Music]
reconsider after this meeting but these
are my remarks i want to say good
morning my name is deborah nelson and i
am from the town of hanover
until i recently retired i taught
american studies for almost three
decades
at lebanon high school
over the years i taught my students to
take the act of voting seriously
and encourage them to volunteer on
campaigns so they would understand the
importance of political engagement
they studied the foundations of
representational government
and they learn to research positions
and
then
to select candidates based on these
positions now mind you none of them
could vote but that was not yet the
point
the one subject that inevitably caused
them tremendous dismay was
gerrymandering
and we looked at many egregious examples
and discussed the insidious reasons
why committees choose to make it very
difficult
for members of one party
to be successful
when running for office
i'm confident
that my former students regard the
majority's congressional maps
with dismay
and even anger
at the blatant gerrymandering that has
taken place
dismay that instead of moving one
community
to balance population numbers between
the two districts
republicans think it wise to move 75
towns
and 365
000 703 people
into a different district
by the way as i'm sure you know from
1883 to 2022
a span of nearly 140 years
only 22 towns have moved districts
i am also sure that some of my students
are angry
that republicans
and independents
in district two but especially
republicans have been deemed unimportant
to their own party
just as democrats in the new district
one will be effectively disenfranchised
my students were taught
that they selected their candidate
and not the other way around
it is my sincere hope that you will
reconsider your maps
and trust in the intelligence of new
hampshire voters to like my students
research positions
and then select their candidates based
on those positions thank you very much
thank you i also have a second letter
that i was given i don't know if there
is time for me to read why don't you
just pass that in i think at this point
if people are not present
thank you so much
thank you
also signed up to speak is bev cotton
from where
good morning
thank you for this opportunity and good
morning chair griffin and members of the
committee
um again
i'm standing here in front of you
against my doctor's wishes because i am
immunocompromised
but i feel that i have no choice but to
do that in order to know that my voice
is being heard here today
again i'm going to also thank you for
your time
your travel
and your efforts in undertaking this
very difficult task
i've been very engaged in your process
since you began
and i've been at all of your hearings
and work sessions
i did this because i was concerned
and i needed to feel more sure that this
was going to be a fair and transparent
process
along with 73 other towns represented
over 500 000 people our very red town
passed a warn article
roughly two to one supporting fair
and public process
and also raised the issue that we wanted
our own
representation where we constitutionally
qualified for that
our population is just over nine
thousand
we thought we might be heard
this is not
partisan
it is in the interest of democracy
and upholding our constitution to the
extent possible
so all this time i've been pretty
anxious to see the proposed maps for
hillsborough county
on map 15a
we achieved the outcome our constitution
provides for
and we were uncoupled from a town that
we had no commonality with
and were finally standing alone sharing
flow tario's with the neighboring town
on map 15 b however we are coupled with
yet a different town that we share
nothing with
no schools no emergency services nothing
so we're back to where we were without
our own reps attached to a town that we
have no interest with
then we came to our congressional
district maps
one carried the tradition of largely
leaving the map unchanged except for a
minor adjustment to equalize population
and one constructed a very convoluted
drawing of the map which really seems to
make little sense despite the efforts to
make a case for the consolidation of the
southern tier
at the expense of fragmenting the
seacoast area among other weaknesses
it does however give mr sepanek the gift
of guaranteeing his promise
of electing a republican
to a congressional seat in 2022
any semblance of con petition
in our congressional districts is gone
particularly as it relates to primaries
representative lynn commented
that of course it's political it's an
exercise conducted in the legislature
and i do understand the difference
between politics
and partisanship
this map b
is clearly both
my face in this process was relatively
negatively impacted by this egregious
display of packing the district
to ensure an outcome which is exactly
what this does
my hope is that you take
our comments
into consideration
and please
re-review
what you've done
thank you very much
thank you
also signed up to speak from tamworth
this morning is gabrielle watson
good morning
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to speak i'm here
gabrielle watson from tamworth
reading a letter sent
by becky o'donnell
of londonderry addressed to the new
hampshire redistricting committee
she it says
my name is becky o'donnell i am a
resident of londonderry i was at the
state house last week when your
redistricting committee presented your
proposals for redistricting maps
i am particularly concerned about the
republican proposal for congressional
district maps which clearly shows
favoritism to the republican party just
as the chair of the new hampshire
republican party promised earlier this
year
the purpose of redistricting is to
protect the right of all citizens to
have their vote counted equally
not to guarantee that one party has a
strong advantage
over another political party
what you are doing is gerrymandering
as your congressional map clearly shows
what we new hampshire voters want is
fairness and redistricting not
gerrymandered maps i ask that you
rethink your maps thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak from lebanon is
paulinov sayas
good morning
my name is paulina seaus i live and work
in lebanon new hampshire which is in
grafton county
i would like to express my concern about
the currently proposed maps for house
seats
even though hanover is eligible for its
own district based on the population
size the current proposals from either a
majority or minority did not grant that
representation
as of the 2020 census the population of
hanover was 11
hundred seventy people
every three thousand four hundred forty
four people are supposed to get their
own state representative
this technically diminishes the voice of
hanover voters and is not fair
thus i strongly suggest adopting the map
from mapathon which takes hanover's
population size into account and grants
the city its own district
my second concern is about the
congressional proposal from the
republicans
this is the biggest shift of new
hampshire towns in 140 years without a
good reason except for pure
gerrymandering
it packs republicans into congressional
district 1 and democrats into
congressional district 2
thus making it very unlikely for
democrats to win in cd1 and impossible
for republicans to win in city 2.
this will eliminate the competitive
nature of new hampshire elections
if members of the same party win year of
the year
this will disenfranchise the voters and
they will be less motivated to
participate in future elections
it really is disconcerting that the
republican party takes away the power of
members of its own party
in the congressional district too
thus i speak against the republican
proposal and called to adopt either a
democratic or a mapathon proposal for
congressional redistricting
my third concern is about this process
poor communication with the people who
elected you
the public was given short notice
there is no interactive option to attend
this public hearing online
and the special committee did not fully
disclose what criteria they used in
creation of their maps
or how the reconciliation process will
be handled
this is not open or transparent
thank you for your attention i submitted
my testimony in writing as well
thank you thank you
judith ackerson from franklin
good morning judith mackerson franklin
i'm
pleased to be here from a community that
did sign on to a resolution
asking for
fair and open uh process in
redistricting
and um
i didn't prepare any written statements
so just
bear with me
a couple of points that i wanted to make
one is that
during during the thick of covid last
year
it was such a gift to the citizens of
new hampshire to be able to participate
in hearings in in the governmental
process
through a very well-run zoom
platform
certainly it was proven that it could be
done and it was done very well
uh it was certainly
helpful for me not wanting to
travel down to concord uh when you
really didn't know who you'd be sitting
with
and um
that was a that was a gift that you gave
to the people of new hampshire
and i felt
some some hope that this would transfer
into
other other hearings of this sort i'm
very disappointed that it has not been
available to the citizens of new
hampshire
i also um
i'm thinking about the people who run
for
political office
obviously we're all coming from our own
different political parties we have
republicans running we have democrats
running
once that person is elected however
i feel that they have an obligation to
represent their community
if you've been
voted to represent say the community of
franklin
um
you may not have been elected by every
person in that community
but i feel that your interest should be
in
recognizing the needs of your whole
community and listening to people from
both sides
and
i think the this process shows that
sometimes you're very shut down
and it's it's you know who do i have to
please not what is the right thing to do
so i hope that you will really take
take to heart
that when you are elected
you are elected four-year-old whole
community for your whole constituency
not just the people that voted for you
thank you for your time
thank you for coming and speaking
alvin c has signed up to speak from
loudoun
thank you madam chairman and member of
the committee my name is alvin c i live
in loudoun
and i wanted to
address the
congressional districts i think that the
map shown on map 18b
is grossly
uh gerrymandered and should be rejected
outright
the map shown on 18a
is laudable simply because it only
required one town to be shifted there
may have been a different town or a pair
of towns that could have been shifted to
accomplish the same thing but the
intent was there
but however
i prefer the map submitted by the
mapathon project
as being a much more concise and
district with um
less
bumps and
uh um
this uh
um
you know basically a a
much more concise shape
than what we have now
then as far as and i won't go into any
more elaboration on that
just to save time
for the house districts i would
encourage you to adopt maps that
provide for the smallest size districts
possible
and reduce the number of towns and
cities that are
merged together just so that the
distribution of representatives is more
uniform thank you very much
thank you
kate kuhn from peterborough
good morning
thank you for the opportunity to present
testimony this morning i am kate
from peterborough i'm a member of the
league of women voters and open
democracy
and i have followed very closely from
the beginning the redistricting process
that you
and the fair maps coalitions are
embarked upon
there's a theme this morning so i too am
from one of the 74 towns that
resoundingly passed on a bipartisan
basis in my town as well
a citizen petition warrant article
calling for fair transparent and
nonpartisan redistricting process
we are at an inflection point right now
to assure that the maps that come out of
this process are not partisan
redistricting
they determine a representative
democracy of our state for the next 10
years that's a weighty responsibility
but it can be done well
thank you for your hard work to make
sure that this does happen
i am reading two short statements for
citizens who are not able to be here in
person
and the first one addressed to your
committee is from ann garland of lebanon
to members of the house special
committee on redistricting in looking at
the recently proposed new hampshire
congressional map
i am trying to understand the criteria
the committee used in drawing the two
new hampshire congressional districts
in fact the criteria was never revealed
despite scores of voter requests to do
so
so why after 140 years of a consistent
congressional district map
drawn by republicans does the new
proposal no longer resemble its
predecessors
if you considered compactness as a
criteria this certainly has not been
achieved
cd1 looks like an angry voter shouting
out at cd2
its chin is jutting out westward its
hooked nose overhangs an open mouth
and the back of its head drops down to
shoulders outlined by a ridge of town
towns
oddly allocated to the other district
cd2
what possible criteria could have
created such a figure
moreover the proposed congressional map
has shifted the partisan balance of the
districts
what justification do you have for
packing democrats into district 2
and moving more republicans into
district 1
and making both districts less
competitive
if one of the redistricting principles
was political fairness this clearly has
not been met
what has been accomplished is that
republican democratic and unaffiliated
voters now have had the power of their
votes diminished which is a sad
accomplishment indeed
there is no other conclusion but the
dishonesty and gerrymandering have been
at work
you have the power to change this it is
not too late for a do-over and rather
than letting the candidates pick the
voters please work within the committee
to come up with a congressional map that
lets the voters pick the candidates
make the congressional maps more
competitive it would be the right and
the smart thing to do
just as your fellow republicans have
done for a hundred years before
in garland of lebanon
and this one is even shorter
dear committee this is from stephen
bourne of rye is this letter shorter i
just feel bad because i i had somebody
not read a letter so i know but i didn't
use my three minutes well that's what
i'm keeping in mind so that's i want to
let everybody know what we are both
again thank you
dear committee at your rockingham county
listening session i reminded you that
your predecessors were adamant the
people assured no group of men
pervert the ends of government for their
own emolument article 10 of the new
hampshire bill of rights
what means of redress do you lisa leave
us
if you put one group above another by
continuing to gerrymander new hampshire
districts
over 37 percent of new hampshire voters
are registered undeclared but you are
stacking the deck against us by packing
party-leaning communities into opposite
districts what respect can our youth and
younger generations have for our
democracy
if you continue to rig the system and
put party above people i implore you to
have the fortitude to free new hampshire
of the slightest scent of gerrymandering
the mapathon project proves that there
are better solutions our democracy only
functions as designed when our leaders
climb above partisanship
if you are struggling to stand up to
party pressure feel free to blame me and
all the others who want to keep our
democracy from being perverted by
political parties the 74 communities who
voted to tell you they want fair and
open redistricting are a statistically
significant sample
clearly communicating new hampshire does
not want to be gerrymandered
respectfully yours stephen born rye
author of consuming government thank you
very much for allowing me to testify
thank you
dan mcguire from epsom the honorable dan
mcguire
thank you very much madam chair members
of the committee for the record my name
is dan mcguire and i'm from epsom
it's such a pleasure to be back in this
fantastic room after so many months away
new hampshire
is less than one-half of one percent of
the united states
and therefore we're like the flea on the
dog's back you know we're along for the
ride
but it behooves us to try to
influence
the united states as much as we can
and we clearly believe in that
in the presidential case because we have
the first in the nation primary and the
purpose of which
is to exert our influence on the choice
of the two
[Music]
presidential candidates
to to have outsized
influence there
we also have an outsized influence in
the u.s
senate simply by the structure of it
we have 2 percent of the u.s senate
comes from new hampshire despite our
much tinier size
so the question is
in the u.s
congress u.s house
how can we have
an
an extra influence
right how can we how can we um
create a situation
where our representatives
are as effective as possible
the us house runs on two principles just
like most other legislative bodies
majority and seniority
people in the majority have obviously a
considerable more influence than people
in the minority
but even so even more so in the us house
than than our house
seniority counts
right it's the senior members the
committee chairs and other leadership
in the u.s house
that control that organization
of the majority right this the senior
members of the majority the committee
chairs and so on
take for example the speaker of the
house
right
someone
uh representative pelosi
who comes from a very safe district
right someone who's been in the house
for decades
and has slowly increased her
seniority
and more
responsibility and so on
our current system of electing
u.s representatives almost guarantees us
that we will not have much influence in
the u.s house
because the seats are unsafe
right someone in a safe seat and our
system by the way is is very beneficial
to incumbents right we have an extremely
late primary
which which helps incumbents
but someone in a safe seat
doesn't have to spend a lot of time
and effort running for reelection
the re-election is more assured so they
can build their seniority
right so
the majority's plan
which
improves the safety of the seeds
number one make sure that we will always
have a new hampshire representative in
the majority
and number two means that that because
the seed is safe the person
the representatives
can build their influence
in the u.s house
and rise through the ranks become
committee chairs become in leadership
and have more influence
the current system
where representatives need to spend huge
amounts of time
running for reelection being careful
not creating waves
almost guarantees that they cannot
become in leadership and therefore have
very little influence
in the us congress
thank you
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is gail kinney
from kanan
madam chair and members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to appear
before you today
i appreciate your hard work
so for the record my name is gail kinney
i am a resident of canaan
i'm also a pastor with the united church
of christ
and as i've conveyed to you previously
as i view this whole redistricting
process and have been watching on what
you're doing
i view this both through a moral lens
and through the lens of a resident of a
community which
has been robbed of its constitutional
right to a single town representative
and according to the proposal
the majority proposal
i am a resident of a town that will
continue
to be robbed
of that right to a single town
representative
so i still have a question for you that
i've had from the beginning
and that is how did you approach the
matter of part two article 11 of the new
hampshire constitution that says that
new hampshire towns with a sufficient
population
shall
shall have their own representative
district
i would have hoped that from day one as
this committee gathered that you would
have started by asking yourselves
what are the communities in the state of
new hampshire that are now
on
put in representative districts that are
unconstitutional
and then how can we cure that in the
redistricting process
so if you didn't make that um rising to
to cure the unconstitutional nature of
so many i think of 62 districts in new
hampshire and make the change
why wasn't that a priority and i hope
that you will explain that to everyone
in the state
so you've heard from the canaan select
board you've heard from canaan residents
about the unconstitutionality of our
current district
but it's clear that even though
i would say there's been a slight
improvement in terms of the the coupling
of of towns in your proposals
kanan still is robbed of that single
town representative and so i just wonder
what did shall mean to you as you went
through this process
and why didn't xiaomi shall for the town
of canaan and so just a really quick
comment about congressional districts
just say my husband
votes in every election um federal state
and local
without fail but he is also completely
apolitical and nonpartisan
um but he took a look at the map
the new congressional district one and
he laughed he thought it was a joke he
thought you can't be serious this is an
embarrassment
and before this process even started we
heard from a leader of one of the
political parties in the state saying
that we're going to use this process to
create an absolutely guaranteed
district for our party
and then what has happened i hope that
you would do differently
but it looks like you have become or the
majority has become handmaidens for that
promise from a party leader
and i would say that that is simply an
embarrassment it's an embarrassment for
you it's an embarrassment for our state
we've never had this kind of
gerrymandering in congressional
districts before and now is not a time
to start so again from that moral lens i
pray that you will go back to the
drawing board and you will do something
that passes the smell test and if not
we who are here we who are concerned
about that would have just no recourse
but to ask you
have you no shame thank you so much
next signed up to speak
is bernie cameron from deerfield
thanks
thank you
bernie cameron from deerfield new
hampshire and thank you
for having these hearings after the
preliminary maps have been drawn
yeah come down i know that at the
hearings that we had earlier that this
was certainly requested and thank you
for honoring that
i want to just make three quick points
i wanted to address um district one of
rockingham county
i wanted to point out that the minority
standard deviation is considerably less
than the majority one
but more than that
i want you to know i've lived in
deerfield 50 years now
if you stop anyone on the street in
deerfield and show them these two maps
and they look at the one of us with
auburn and candia
they
they would be astounded
the remark that they would say that i've
heard over and over
from people from all
parties republican democrat independent
is
we don't have anything in common with
candy and auburn
and that's the truth candier and auburn
are very manchester-centric towns they
have 101
fast highway that brings them
there quickly they have most of their
business most of their is manchester
in deerfield
similar to northwood in nottingham we go
all over
many of us work i have services in
concord
some are in exeter some in dover some in
manchester but it's pretty spread
between the four
as a previous speaker mentioned we were
originally part of the town of
nottingham
our cultures are very similar
i would really um intercede for you to
please honor the minority plan for
deerfield
second of all i am in awe of the work
that you do
i've been
paying much more attention to
redistricting this time
and i've come to learn the constraints
that you're working under between the
federal constitution
our state constitution
one vote one person
the deviations etc it's obvious from all
the towns
that testified during the hearings
that they want their own district it's
very important to them
i would encourage you to look at our
state constitution
[Music]
and to
decide are there areas where there could
be modifications where there could be
amendments
to try to honor
this yearning
that people are expressing every speaker
is talking about that they have it all
the hearings this is something that we
need to do in deerfield this is
something we need to do in new hampshire
the third thing which i wasn't going to
speak about but after hearing comments
about
we need saved districts
that gave me a visceral response
it is so against a democracy
and against our history of voting in
this country
to hear someone actually advocate
for safe districts
i grew up
with a very um with immigrant parents so
i'm a first generation
they were so excited to come to this
country and to be able to vote
and they spent and taught me to spend so
much time at looking at individual
candidates no matter the party i have
voted in both parties
but to look for the best candidate
never
never would i ever consider
to try to keep a safe
candidate
thank you
thank you miss cameron
also signed up to speak is barbara
parcelli from concord
good morning my name is barbara piccelli
and i've lived in concord for 23 years
i read on behalf of david murray of
tuftenburg
whose opinion i strongly support
david's words follow
members of the special new hampshire
house redistricting committee
good morning
i'm writing this to ask you to stop the
gerrymandering and make the
redistricting of new hampshire fair for
elections
it's time both sides democrats and
republicans
make the changes to truly allow for we
the people
this new gerrymandering policy
is damaging to fair elections for years
to come
please allow
a non-partisan group to redistrict the
state
so that all votes count properly
and do not give favor to one side or the
other
thank you on behalf of david and myself
for your consideration
and hard work
thank you
david andrews from chichester has signed
up
david andrews chichester
i think i more than anyone else could
understand the enormity of the task
before you and how hard you guys have
been working on the
house maps for
new hampshire in particular
i could probably spend a couple hours
talking about the nuances of each of the
counties i'm not going to don't worry
about that
i'm just going to bring up a couple of
points
one that's been brought up
with the majorities map in hillsborough
manchester is allowed
if you look at the deviation of plus or
minus 5
you could give them between 32 and 35
seats with 34 being the closest to the
ideal
with the majority map giving only 32
seats to manchester
it would only take a difference of 18
people in the wards in order to make
that map go over the 5
and thus
make it invalid
overall
so i would ask that you look at
either the minorities map which gives 33
or the map-a-thons map which gives 34 to
manchester and i think helps
make the rest of the county
better off
another of the issues is in sullivan
county where
both the majority and the minorities
maps use a point
between uh i believe it's lebanon and
i forget exactly where but they both use
that point
and i believe that the majorities map
uses that point
to the benefit of the map overall so i
think it's it's a reasonable uh use of
that
technically contiguous point
um
oh it's between cornish craw
and newport
so
in the majorities they use that to kind
of enhance the map
the problem with the minorities map is
that
they use one district across it one way
and then they use a floaterial across it
the other way and i'm not sure if that's
technically
allowed because both districts would
then not be contiguous because they kind
of cross over each other at that point
and therefore i would think that that's
not technically allowed
the other problem with the sullivan map
is that with the majority map
it goes below the kind of minus five
percent deviation to negative six
i don't think overall that that's an
issue in that
the
the whole point is to make sure that
people are not under
represented
and so in the case of manchester that
would be the case where it would go over
kind of the five percent people would be
underrepresented but in sullivan county
they would be kind of overrepresented
and because of the way that we apportion
representatives by county
um
for instance belknap county gets
18.502 or 18.498 so they get 18. so
they're kind of on the the
uh being kind of underrepresented
overall but sullivan counties on the
other end and thus kind of is
overrepresented so if we are going to
apportion representatives by county i
don't think it's uh overall issue if
some
are more
uh
represented than others if we're going
to do it that way anyway
it doesn't make
a lot of sense to me to
to worry of too much about the the
negative deviation rather than the the
positive deviation of someone being
underrepresented and
actually we were able to draw three maps
for three counties that use that kind of
extra negative deviation in order to
draw
what i believe are better maps
one for sullivan county which
doesn't use that
point
in
between those towns but allows for all
three of the eligible towns in that
county to have their own representatives
um one for
carroll county which allows for
all but wolfeboro all those towns in
wolfeboro to to get their own
districts and then one in
stratford county which does a a good job
of
limiting the um number of
towns that don't get their own
representatives and
um it gives
summer's worth kind of two
representatives uh and we'll be
submitting those those maps to you um
and
uh i also went through all of the
different kind all the different
submissions between the minority the
majority and the mapathon groups and
kind of um
went through and
chose kind of the best of of each of the
maps and there's some of each
and
actually went through and drew
kind of two new maps one for hillsboro
that uses kind of a combination and one
for rockingham that uses a combination
of kind of all three
it uses parts of the republican
plan
it uses the
the part of the democrat plan that was
talked about with deerfield so it puts
deerfield with nottingham and northwood
and then it uses part of the maplecon
plan to come up with a plan that that
i believe is a lot better than all three
so combined we we we made a pretty
decent map for rockingham county
so that's kind of just what i wanted to
talk about for the for the house maps
for the congressional maps
i understand
what the kind of goal
of the majority proposal was it was to
you know create one safe seat
for democrats and one safe seat for
republicans
the problem is that i think that it may
be a little bit short-sighted of a of a
thought in that
especially with today's announcement
that governor sununu is going to be
running for governor and not the senate
there could be
kind of no competitive statewide races
in
in the state of new hampshire and thus
if you look at
republican voters in cd2 because
if chris pappas runs in cd1 it's
probably going to be a competitive race
no matter what even with this kind of
shift i would think that he he would
have finished he would have lost by
probably two percent in
2020 and i think he would have won by a
little bit in 2018 so it would still be
a very competitive race in cd2 that's
not the case there would be
oh annie custer would win by a very
large margin and if there's no other
statewide races
that are competitive
what do republican voters
in cd
have to vote for
they
you could see a vastly
lower voter turnout in terms of
republican voters all across cd2 and
thus
could lose the new hampshire house of
representatives for the republicans
could cause
issues with the new hampshire senate and
for the executive council i'm not sure
that the tradeoff
of
one republican
congressman for the u.s is worth the new
hampshire
house of representatives or the new
hampshire senate or the new hampshire
executive council it it it seems that
it's almost like
kind of
giving up on the possibility with with
the shifts that we're seeing in the
political landscape it's very
conceivable that in you know two four
eight years we would be sending two
republicans to washington rather than
just one and under the
majorities plan for the congressional
seats
it's conceivable that we could send two
democrats but
it
would be very very very unlikely to ever
send two republicans with those set up
maps
so i'd ask that you
look at the minorities proposal which
barely changes it
but more importantly look at the
mapathon map which
puts communities of interest together
cuts down on high school saus that are
split public health regions that are
split counties that are split
we shifted the map a little bit
in order to bring those communities
together
thank you
so people here and people watching are
aware the the last speaker david andrews
was a mapper with the mapathon project
and he has spoken before but that's uh
why you were able to hear some very
specific references to maps because
he has spent a lot of time on this
also signed up to speak is linda bundy
linda linda's from antrim welcome
thank you good morning madam chair and
members of the committee i am linda
bundy from antrim
when considering the maps i focused on
ones submitted by committee members and
the mapathon project
i did know additional maps submitted by
others and believe this interest and
participation is positive and benefits
us all
with respect to the maps for the new
hampshire house of representatives i was
pleased to see that antrim is not in a
floatarial district in any of the maps
generally speaking the base districts
are compact and keep the towns in our
school district together
one drawback to the map submitted by the
majority of the committee is the very
large floatarial district in the
southwest part of the county
i also understand that giving manchester
32 representatives may lead to
violations that could be disputed in
court
i think either the maps submitted by the
minority or
the mapathon project map best serve more
towns than the ones submitted by the
majority
in regards to the united states
congressional maps i realized that
changes in population
made district changes necessary
the map submitted by the minority
achieves change in an elegant fashion by
moving just one town hampstead
this map has low deviation and maintains
relatively competitive districts
the mapathon project map moves 22 towns
but maintains
more communities of interest such as
school districts
shared water services and shared
emergency services
this map has low deviation and a good
balance between rural and urban areas
in contrast the map proposed by the
majority moves 75 towns and one-fourth
of the entire population of the state
there is no valid reason for such
drastic change
although this map has a very low
deviation
there is little else to recommend it
the partisan balance in the districts
has been shifted so that district 1
leans strongly republican
and district 2 means democratic
republican voters in district 2
and democratic voters in district 1
will have their voices diminished
this is not what it means to draw fair
maps i ask that the committee approved
the map submitted by the minority
or the mapathon project or some similar
map but not the one submitted by the
majority i thank you for your time and
your work and the opportunity to speak
today
madam chair
are you allowing people to read
statements from others
i
unfortunately made one exception to my
rule because the speaker really had not
taken any time so if you could submit
the letter
we will take it staff is going to copy
scan and committee members will get an
email with all of the submitted
testimony for today
thank you
question of the chair please plant him
chair
representative weber over on my right
representative weber
thank you very much madam chair i just
wondered as a follow-up
to the gentleman who testified just
previously
is there a place that members of the
public can see the mapathon maps or
other maps that are presented by members
of the public because we were
promised that that would happen and i
have yet to see them go up on our
website
actually i know that there are some
mapathon maps that were submitted
previously i don't know the current
status i will allow david andrews if he
wants to
if you're are you able to speak to that
or does brian biel need to speak to it
just to that because i am not allowing
questions honestly no madam chair i was
not asking of them i was asking you as
to where they would be posted i i'm just
trying to cover myself in regards to
representative lin who i did not let
utter a word so
um
if you can just speak directly to that
point as to where members of the public
can find the mapathon maps yes madam
chair thank you
the
mapathon's house recommendations
have been submitted to the committee's
website
and they are also available at uh open
democracy you want to come a little
closer to the mike
uh
so they are available on the committee's
website
uh and they are also available at
opendemocracynh.org
thank you so that means if you go to the
the special committee on redistricting
page you can get to it from the home
page for the house you click on the
special committee
view submitted testimony that will be in
the center
of the page about a quarter of the way
down and then you can look to the
corresponding bill for the submissions
because while we may be talking about
the cd
and the house and other races there's
actually a specific bill number
associated with each of those sets of
maps
all right see this is what happens when
you start to let people speak up all
right representative mcguire
i just
wanted to confirm the mapathon maps are
readily available from the
committee's website and they are
readable and you can see them
thank you for the explanation i
appreciate it because i was unable to
find them
thank you representative weber also
signed up to speak is representative
horgan
thank you very much madam chairman can
you hear me with the mask on or should i
take it off no we can hear you thank you
okay so i'm representing timothy
horrigan i'm currently from stratfor
district 6.
if the majority plan passes i forget
what the number of my district is but it
will be somewhat different but currently
i represent the towns of durham and
madbury
so first quickly to address the
congressional map
as i agree with others it's blatantly
gerrymandered although i think um
i think that might backfire because it
is a
district that could be flipped from
could easily
be won by a democrat including the uh
incumbent if he chooses to run again i
know you're not protecting the
incumbents but if he runs again he's uh
he'll probably be a very strong
candidate in whichever however the
district is drawn and if
and there are other democrats who live
in the district even though it's
technically not required but
um
who could also put up a strong challenge
so that could backfire um this house
plan the majority plans are
gerrymandered not quite as blatantly
gerrymandered as the ones that were
presented to us 10 years ago and i
applaud you
i applaud you and anna
and the member from
the member from charlestown
representative smith from charlestown so
it's been a
project the process has
been
not totally transparent but has been
much more transparent than it was last
time
and
the plan last year also backfired on the
republicans because roughly half of the
republicans who voted for the plan in
2012 were then
not there in 2013 most in most cases
because they had been defeated in the
reelection thing so any
these plans are always unpredictable
especially with the uh with the house
plans doesn't matter how much you want
to slander the one side or the other it
may not end up being slanted to that
side
um as for uh
as for this plan our the state
constitution um
clearly states that towns
and i'm not i've heard this about a
hundred times that towns are
entitled to their own a base district
with their um
with their own reps if it's within if
it's reasonably practicable and that's
um and also
the districts have to be contiguous and
there are um
there are several districts like
like there's some that are joined only
at one point deep in the woods that's
obviously not contiguous at all there's
others whose continuity is questionable
including
on the coast coast map not that there's
necessarily a different way to draw it
but um
district one the northernmost district
uh
it has
a few populated towns in the northern
part of the county and then a few others
north of berlin and then the rest of it
is a
there's much of totally unpopulated
townships with no high
few of any roads connecting them um
i think certainly the
historically
um how we got have 400 members by the
way which uh and i certainly think after
our experience
during the pandemic i might
i think that will create a lot of
difficulties for us having so many
so many members a smaller body probably
could have dealt
more easily with the crisis but we
survived and here we are
the reason that was because originally
each town
sent its own
rep or reps if his population was over a
certain amount
now it's also part of where the 100 year
salary came from because that was a
figure that every town could afford
the
and then eventually and then they had
like some provisions for towns with
small populations would just send one
for part of the tent for just one or two
terms out of the uh they would share
they would share a district and each
town would send one for two years or
four years or six
during the ten year period between the
reapportionment so that
they got up to i think about 430
folding seats here in rep's hall and
that just got to be totally impractical
and that was where they came up with the
constitutional amendment which says uh
400 or actually it's 375 to 400 but it's
always we've always gone the maximum
number of seats so that's
that's where that came from and
and eventually and so that was and that
principle was then carried over in 2006
to the constitutional amendment which
was trying to guarantee towns that are
um
at the so-called iodine number which
this year i guess at 3044
to have their own seed to the base
district and um
and i think um
and i
i think this it's i think this um
could be honored more if we uh
and i hate to i hate to break
try to dispute a bipartisan
uh consensus when there is
so few things that the two parties agree
on but i think the plus or minus five
percent the rationale for it is in my
mind totally unclear and i've tried to
see what it is
we and
other states with large legislatures and
small populations including our
neighbors to the east and west vermont
they actually use a higher deviation
vermont
they have they successfully
they successfully
got a plan
put in place without a federal court
challenged ahead
plus or minus 10 percent a 20 deviation
similar in maine
and
their cases
their cases their law actually allows
them to divide
towns and city wards in half which we
can't do here so
i think we could could get away i
mean i
hesitate to open up a can of worms but
we probably
should have started with a greater
deviation in fact you're probably
drawing at the plans it's not easy
i've
got hold of the software 10 years ago
the software this year
years ago is a similar there is a i
don't know what is on purpose or not but
there is a computer down at the base of
the lob that
any member can sit down at and
draw up their own maps the software is
actually
fairly user friendly so that part of the
process is
actually not that terrible but it is
terrible deciding how you're going to go
about
doing it and
i think probably
we may have started from the wrong place
which is minimizing the deviation they
probably should have started
with giving every town its own base
district and then
combined smaller town
combine smaller towns with other small
towns combine smaller towns with
neighboring larger towns putting full
terriels i think they should have uh
they should have they should have
done that first and then worry about the
deviations uh
last
even though you would have a larger
deviation that i think the public would
still be satisfied with it
and it would still
it would still survive a federal court
challenge and um
and finally i'll say my district is one
that i don't understand why the majority
drew it the way it is um
um
durham
durham um
durham gets a base district with four
people which is which is fine we um we
took the last 10 years we were combined
with madbury for six
but they decided that madbury should go
for lee and dover ward 4
and i'm not even sure exactly where
the boundaries of dover ward 4 is i do
know the southern boundary of butts
madbury
along its entire length and those are
three communities which um
so those madbury and lee for example
they're in the same school district with
durham um so
it's understandable it makes sense for
those to be together but i'm not sure
why particularly makes sense
for those three towns to also be with
that one ward in dover or anyone who
wore it in dover you know i'm
i mean i'm prepared for that plan to
pass and i'll have to educate myself
more about dover politics because
somebody somebody will have to run in a
floatario that has
300 something
uh
about 27 500 people
including you know
including
those three towns and then then they
somewhat randomly selected ward of uh
the city to the north and not that
not that dover and durham and maverick
lee are in a different uh planets or
anything but there's uh
especially with the local politics don't
really interact that much even though
it's a very short distance
and there's certainly much worse
floatarios out there so
good luck with the process i know it's i
know it's not easy and certainly no
matter what you draw nobody's going to
be satisfied with it and also you don't
really know
what the voters are going to do
next year when we actually send them out
there to vote and the
other point i mean is like this one's
very important this is the first
this is the first uh
apportionment since the 2020 election
and
the january
16th 2021 insurrection which i
personally view as a very traumatic
historical event even i know not
everybody
around the table feels that way but
those things are very sensitive parties
are very divided and the elections are
something that
should bring everyone together and
should be done fairly in a
a non-partisan fashion and
so i think we want to have uh the best
possible elections both
in terms of how we apportion the
districts and also then of course in
terms of how we conduct the election
once the districts are
are put in place so
um
anyway that's basically i i think
basically i think uh
you might want to consider going with a
larger deviation and then actually
respecting the state constitution for
the house process it might be uh
i know you're
i know you're kind of late in the
process but i think there probably is
still time to you know
redo the plan redo a more constitutional
plan especially since there's a
possibility
there may be a lawsuit based on that i
don't know all right thank you
representative horgan
don house from belma
belmont excuse me is here uh just
committee members you were handed a
package that has
a letter from mr house
welcome good afternoon now
good afternoon members of the special
redistricting committee
my name is don house and i'm a resident
of belmont which is located in
belknap county
i created warrant article 26 on fair
non-partisan redistricting that appeared
on belmont's march
2021 town election
this one article passed with a strong
majority of voters expressing their
preference for a fair non-partisan
redistricting process
74 towns in new hampshire have passed
similar resolutions
transparency and fairness are crucial to
restore voter confidence in our election
process
i've reviews that i've reviewed the
proposed district map by this committee
and other groups such as open democracy
based on population alone
eight of the 11 towns and cities in
belknap county meet the criteria for
their own representation
however none of the maps proposed give
all eight of these towns their own
representation
the feedback from belknap county voters
shared on october 19th hearing
indicated that tilton alton
gilford meredith and barnstead should
have their own representative
instead of sharing rep with other towns
all of the proposals disregarded this
feedback
i think the most important principles
for redistricting belknap county are to
apply the principles in this order
each town that has a population of at
least 34 or 44 should receive its own
state representative
towns with populations less than that
can be combined with a plateau district
laconia should remain intact
towns are best served by representatives
that are elected from their own town or
the smallest floaterial district that
combines towns
the smaller the district the better the
representation
based on their population some town
should be given multiple representatives
the use of ploterial districts
and combining two adjacent towns to
share representatives should be
minimized
if any towns remain unassigned after
these first principles are applied then
larger deviations should be considered
i applied these principles to build up
county
and as as everyone says we get we should
get 18 representatives
this one everyone's agreement with
but in terms of when i apply my criteria
above alton would get one rep with
another floatarial rep with barnstead
barnstein would get one rep with another
plotarial rep with alton
belmont would receive two reps
center harbor new hampton would share a
forterial
guilford would have their own two reps
laconia would have five reps
meredith would have two reps
new hampton and center harbor as i said
sheriff rotarial
stamberton gets one rep and tilt in one
rep
in summary
nine of the eleven towns and cities get
their own representation in my scenario
the two towns with populations less than
that are combined in full tarial
now contrast that with the proposed plan
for
belmont which takes away their two
representatives now
and combines belmont
with
ward 4 and laconia
and gilmanton so they now have four reps
so that to me is going in the wrong
direction
and as
some of you probably
for some of you will probably object to
my scenario because of the deviations
would might exceed the general rule of
plus or minus 10 5
i've reviewed the supreme court
decisions that this plus or minus five
percent is based on
and the u.s supreme court has allowed
for greater deviations when there is a
legitimate constitutional purpose and it
seems to me like
adhering to the new hampshire
constitution about what town should
receive their representatives is a
legitimate constitutional purpose
i believe that redistricting processes
become too focused on this general rule
and ignore the new hampshire
constitution rule
concerning towns having their own state
representative when they meet the
population criteria
my other feedback is on the two
congressional districts for new
hampshire i know you've heard a lot
about this already
they should be drawn to minimize the
number of towns that switch districts
most of the towns in the southeastern
portion should stay with a single
district
the proposed maps are clearly
gerrymandered for the political benefit
of republicans
long-standing competitive districts
that have been drawn by republicans are
now being redrawn
the existing congregate congressional
districts have remained nearly the same
for 140 years
but now they're shifting them
this break with long-standing precedent
further underscores how fundamentally
unfair these lines are
both congressional seats should remain
competitive mirroring the state as a
whole
in summary
the maps as proposed don't meet the
criteria that most voters indicated were
important to them
the
maps need to better reflect the feedback
from the voters
eliminate the gerrymandering that has
spoiled the maps
redistricting
impacts many issues in our daily lives
the drawing of districts lines not only
determines who is elected
but also how the state's financial
resources are allocated for schools
hospitals roads and other services
everyone in new hampshire deserves far
better than the majority of party maps
released so far
please revise these maps to reflect the
voter feedback that you have heard today
thank you
thank you mr house
also signed up to speak is
representative brian sullivan
thank you madam chair thank you to the
committee for hearing our testimony
i am brian sullivan i represent sullivan
county district one as does lee oxenham
who spoke earlier
the towns in sullivan one are plainfield
cornish grantham and springfield
today i'm going to focus
primarily on the sullivan county map
and specifically on the majority map
to start off
i believe this the southern part of the
county has been undone pretty well
it doesn't make many changes
and frankly
it's been working and will continue to
work the only change was really shifting
unity and goshen
and
that's fine it keeps things pretty much
the way they are
in the northern part of the county
there's some problems
and as
representative oxenham mentioned earlier
part of that problem is corbyn park
you can't see corbin park on this map
but it's a very large game preserve
right in the middle of the northern
section of
sullivan county
and it really splits things up
and frankly it splits up my district now
because of the corbin park
i live almost on the edge of corbin park
the only way i could get to plainfield
part of my district
without leaving um grantham
to go into enfield in lebanon would be
to drive a jeep track that's close to my
house and um
frankly i wouldn't put my f-150 on that
track
it is a very rough road you can't get
there from here
so essentially
it makes sense to split grantham and
springfield from cornish and plainfield
what doesn't make sense is splitting up
playing field in cornish
those two towns i heard so many say
earlier two peas in a pod that is indeed
the case they have
more in common than probably any other
two towns in the in the county
so i believe it's essential to keep
those two towns together
cornish and plainfield
are a community
among themselves
this map also has grantham as a separate
district
it's a little bit short
of voters for a separate district but
it's close
um
i think
rather than combining plainfield or i'm
sorry
yes playing field with croydon in
springfield
you could put either croydon
or springfield with grantham
and perhaps put croydon or springfield
with sunapee
those two towns have been made their own
districts
they could take and they're both a
little bit short of voters for their own
district
so i think those two combinations could
work um
the other district that's
bit of a mess is
cornish newport and goshen again it goes
from one side of the county the other
cornish and newport has has been pointed
out only are joined by a point
they have
little of anything in common unlike
cornish and plainfield
and frankly you could have newport and
goshen
form
a two
seat district without including cornish
so
[Music]
i'm not telling you exactly how you need
to do this
the one thing i think is essential keep
cornish and plainfield together
combine springfield and grantham as you
see fit
and leave newport and goshen as a duo
with two seats
i think that would work and i thank you
for your time
thank you
green dodge
good afternoon thank you very much for
allowing us to speak
um
most of what i have to say has been said
before and i miss judge you want to just
i may know but you want to just say
where you're from
i didn't want to do that okay
my name is karine dodge and i live in
derry thank you okay
um
most of what i intended to say has
already been said i don't need to say it
again even though i believe it with all
my heart i i will make this incredibly
short and ask your permission
to read
another person's very very short letter
thank you
i think that was a yes yes
the minority proposal congressional maps
are as unfair to republican voters in
district two
as they are to democratic voters
in district one and all this is so that
the republican party will have an unfair
advantage in winning elections for the
next 10 years
i feel that you were taking away my vote
please stop the gerrymandering
and now i'm speaking for celia randall
who is a um a voter in brookfield
my name is celia randall i live in
brookfield
i am writing to express my outrage at
what i am hearing reported on nhpr and
in reading online articles
for new hampshire journalists concerning
the outright partisan manipulation of my
vote
the proposed gerrymandered plans ensures
a district that will produce a
republican outcome and another that will
likely favor
democrats this plan negates our choices
and creates more of the partisan
conflict which we have all witnessed for
the past several years this is unfair to
new hampshire voters
new hampshire constituents demand of you
to put in place a redistricting plan
that is fair and evenly divided based on
population shifts not political parties
not either one of them
please do not invalidate my voice and
thank you very much for allowing me to
read that thank you
barbara schultz from goffstown
and members you have a letter
from her
i have submitted written testimony but
i'm actually um speaking differently
today um and i thank you for the time to
be here
um you're gonna hear from me that i'm
here because i want fair maps um and i'm
sorry to have to be can you get a little
closer to the mic just so everybody can
hear you um
i'm here to ask for fair maps and i
guess i welcome the opportunity to
address this again but i'm also
disappointed that after hundreds of
people at public hearings and thousands
of people over the 74 town warrant votes
have asked for fair maps we still have
to ask for fair mats
my testimony is with reference mostly to
the majority version of the
congressional
district map
my understanding is you represent the
voices of all the voters
in new hampshire not just those who
voted for you
your obligation
is to your full constituency not stephen
stepanek not the incumbent
and not the game playing that was
referred to by an earlier person about
building power and seniority in congress
your obligation is to every citizen to
ensure that their vote will matter that
their candidate regardless of party has
a fair chance of being elected
the people have spoken loudly and
clearly they want fair maps
thousands of constituents in over 74
towns have overwhelmingly voted for fair
maps
i urge you not to dismiss the relevance
and value of those town warrant votes
most people cannot be here today
or tomorrow at 5. they work they have
child care they have classes
the distance and their personal health
which i have a huge concern standing
very close to this map
to this mic
that town vote is their message their
opportunity to speak
and their voice in this mapping project
please heed their voice
your own legislature through bipartisan
effort the past two legislative sessions
have also voted for fairness
i have to repeat this the people want
fair maths it is your responsibility to
see that this happens
the majority map
for the congressional district is a
waste of everyone's time
it does not even pass the most basic
parameter of being visually compact
it does a disservice to all new
hampshire citizens and our democracy
it most likely will be voted down by
your colleagues in full session
it would hopefully be vetoed by governor
sununu as it does not pass his smell
test
it may end up in the courts
why put forth this wasted effort
chairman griffin
you are here because the citizens of
goffstown elected you
i'd like to restate
the vote of the goffstown people a very
republican town of march of 2020 where
an overwhelming majority 972-642
an overwhelming majority of your
constituency
voted in favor of quote
redrawing the state's maps in a fair
manner for effective representation of
new hampshire's voters
unquote
does your current version of these
congressional district maps meet that
standard
chairman griffin and committee members
tear up your majority congressional map
draft try again
this time and heed
all of the people that you represent in
the state and do the right thing thank
you
thank you
harold lynch from pelham or lind i
believe
harold linde
is this okay
all right thank you madam chairman board
members uh i applaud your time and your
efforts for this i truly appreciate it
i am
selectmen from the town of powell in my
34th year i'm accompanied by charlene
takishan in her fourth year as a town
treasurer
and both of us have served in this
this party house of representatives on
either side by the way just a little
kitchen uh
first of all i want to thank you
for giving palum its rightful
number of representatives
with a population of something around 50
50 000 we were entitled to four seats
in
2012 as we are in 2021-22
didn't get them we got zero and now we
have four thank you
i would point out
that the key thing
to me
is the
change to the
our constitution
which says which we all voted to uphold
says
the key things
a town award shall have its own district
of one or more representative
seats no differences it just if you
qualify you get them
when i looked at the
20 uh 12 sayings i looked i made a
spreadsheet
went through the math
and looked at how many
districts
qualified and didn't get a seat
it would surprise you probably to learn
there are 62 towns
that did not
meant were
unconstitutionally
uh drawn
62.
the town of pelham the town of sullivan
town of atkinson qualified for
seats with no
need for plateau
didn't get them
so i do want to thank you for doing that
for pelham
i will intend to this year
go through the same process
to see and i'd be glad to share that
information if i feel
that either on one side or the other
that it doesn't
meet the requirements of our
constitution and would hope you would
rectify those uh i would probably like
to ask you two things is i'd like to get
the database or for the population i'll
get that from somebody
and uh and who would i send it the
information to
that i would produce relatives the
uh constitutionality of the district
but that's it that's what my
all right
thank you mr lind uh just for general
information when you go to the house
website and you're looking at our maps
you will see in each community a box
and that box will have the population
number in it
the program we used
has those populations loaded into it and
it is the same as the census data
next signed up to speak is
representative suzanne smith
she's still here or not
representative smith
it's harder to see from down here than
you think all right i'm not seeing her
also signed up to speak is
uh
paulana hunt
from rochester i'm sorry i didn't get
that completely right
uh yeah polana hunt hawkins from
rochester thank you so i live in
rochester i think we have a really
dynamic and competitive electorate there
um and frankly i think that some of
these these proposed map changes aim to
eliminate that
one of them is in so in rochester
currently we have nine house seats that
span six wards
uh the majority map also breaks
rochester ward five out with milton and
it creates a very bizarrely shaped
district and no offense to milton but i
think that milton and rochester have
very different needs and it would be
great to keep rochester all within
rochester districts um
something that was brought up at the
stratford county listening session was
not uh was
just person after person was talking
about executive council district two and
i really think something should be done
about that
finally um with congressional district
one
i came of age uh playing sonic the
hedgehog and sonic the hedgehog is a
very great video game but it's a very
terrible congressional district
there's all these little like bumps and
stuff um i think that that's something
that should really be taken a look at
thank you
is representative jackie callie pitts
here
you were
she must have had to have left there
were a couple of people here who left
that is the end of my sign up sheet is
there anybody here this morning who
would like to speak who has not
i'm not seeing anybody so i want to
thank everybody here for coming this
public input session of the special
house committee on redistricting is now
concluded we will be back here tomorrow
at 5 00 pm
um and again thank you i encourage you
to reach out to members individually you
can do it on the website or contact us
personally thank you everybody and have
a great